[Music]
to music greats honored at the 62nd
annual Grammys the late Prince and
nipsey hussle the stars came out with
emotional yet powerful tributes for the
artist
first up asher fka twigs and prince's
protege Sheila E they took the stage to
pay homage to the legend himself he was
with Usher just moments after the group
brought down the Staples Center paying
tribute to Princeton you know he didn't
like a lot of people doing his stuff but
I think he would have loved this moment
yeah man I was so happy to have Sheila E
up there and twigs man his spirit is all
over this place and it's a real heavy
time for the world right now we just
wanted to shine some light and I'm
really happy that we were able to
finally pay tribute or the beginning of
the tribute right it's a prince and it
continues Tuesday so really excited to
have kicked it off here man that's right
the grammy tribute was just a taste of
the upcoming salute to Prince concert
which will air January 28th on CBS it's
been nearly four years since we lost
prints but ballerina misty Copeland who
was close to the Purple Rain singer told
ety now was the perfect time to honor
the high priest of Pop it's been really
difficult you know time just dealing
with the loss of someone who is so
spent so much to me into the world into
the music you are one of his muses he
was he was an incredible mentor to me
and I you know I worked with him on and
off for about five years and so it's
having Sheila II be the one that's kind
of putting it all together I just feel
like this is his fam and everyone that's
a part of it like he I know will be
smiling down
[Music]
[Applause]
dj khaled John Legend and Kirk Franklin
and meek Mill took the stage to honor
Nipsey Hussle life it was a bittersweet
moment on top of a bittersweet night for
nipsey's loved ones the late rapper won
two Grammy Awards on Sunday his first
ever one for Best Rap performance for
his track rack in the middle a collab
featuring rowdy rich and hit boy the
rapper's family posthumously accepted
this award I speak on behalf of our
family of the money and family and in
honor of nip who is a was a phenomenal
vessel nip did it not just for the
awards but for the people and God
allowed him to use this music to speak
his truth his second Grammy win was for
best rap song performance for higher
hits collab with DJ Khaled and John
Legend
the rather see me down to my soil in the
fire
and a sweet tribute you might have
missed nipsey's long time love Lauren
London were a very special accessory on
the carpet a necklace with the photo of
the rapper a photo that was taken at the
2019 Grammy Awards less than two months
before the rapper was shot and killed on
March 31st at the age of 33 he spoke to
the dedication rapper at the Grammys
last year when he was a first-time
nominee getting recognized in the Best
Rap Album category for victory lap I'm
inspired obviously you don't want to get
back and make some new music hum oh I
know how much we put into the album so
you know to be recognized that you mean
a lot you know for my team also
everybody I worked on it
we just excited and you don't have to be
[Music]